esta otra la playa paradisíaca ofrece
actualmente un rostro apocalíptico
[Música]
hasta 2018 usa está valla aún era un
pueblo en el que vivían 600 familias
entre ellas la en su duración
[Música]
mi casa estaba ahí el tubo azul era el
pozo para sacar agua aquí vivíamos con
toda mi familia
y al lado estaban nuestros vecinos la
escuela el templo
zurda ya pasó su existencia en esta
playa y la vio desaparecer bajo las
corrientes de la bahía de bengala
cuando era niño el nivel del agua era
bajo y el mar se daba más o menos a unos
dos kilómetros de aquí
progresivamente el océano fue sacando
alas nos han reubicado tres veces es el
final de santalla el final de este
pueblo de su historia su memoria
todo ello fue barrido por pasados
en 20 años el estado de orissa del que
hace parte del pueblo desataba ya ha
visto a erosionarse el 30 por ciento de
su litoral
los responsables a su vida de las aguas
y ciclones cada vez más frecuentes
un ejemplo entre otros de las
consecuencias del cambio climático en
india
en 2020 las catástrofes naturales le
costaron al país 75 mil millones de
euros
según un informe de la organización
meteorológica mundial en gran parte
debido a los episodios de sequía y aún a
monzón errática vital para la
agricultura la estación de lluvias está
alterada
este rosal está totalmente dañado las
precipitaciones son más escasas pero más
intensas cuando caen algo que desespera
a los granjeros como susana ya que
los cultivos estaban listos para la
cosecha pero de improvisto la lluvia
cayó y lo destruyó todo ya perdimos el
monzón del verano y ahora cuando
necesitamos agua todo está seco corremos
el riesgo de perder también la cosecha
de invierno
entre 2000 es 2019 india registro 321
catástrofes naturales
catástrofes cada vez más intensas y
mortíferas 80 mil personas murieron
durante estos dos últimos decenios
tormentas inundaciones derrumbes
canículas o derretimiento de glaciares
ninguna región del país está exenta
entre las ciudades recientemente
afectadas y plus a finales de julio 24
horas ininterrumpidas de lluvia sacaron
a los dos ríos de su cauce así con doble
es comerciante tres meses después de la
catástrofe los estigmas siguen visibles
de esta marca
el agua subió hasta esta altura y aquí
puede ver otros
aquí el nivel del agua alcanzó cerca de
6 metros en algunos lugares una
treintena de viviendas fueron totalmente
destruidas
esta era la sala de los altos muros
esta casa pertenecía a su hermano
y aquí la habitación
tratamos de salvar lo que pudimos mi
hermano y yo teníamos agua hasta el
cuello cuando tratábamos de amarrar los
muebles y la nevera
así y su hermano salieron ilesos un
milagro todos no contaron con la misma
suerte en el pueblo en esta calle diez
habitantes murieron el cuñado de esta
mujer fue arrastrado por las aguas
el agua empezó a infiltrarse en casa
hacia las tres de la mañana no sabíamos
que había salido para atrás la gente
y pues nunca más volvió
su mujer emocionada se aisló en el
silencio
desastres humanos y materiales
amplificados por otro fenómeno la
urbanización galopante
[Música]
bombay la capital económica del país 20
millones de habitantes se volvió el
símbolo de ello los proyectos
inmobiliarios florecen en detrimento de
su barrera natural los manglares 200
kilómetros cuadrados de bosques y
pantanos que rodean la megalópolis
insular
nata kumar power es medio ambientalista
ayudado por la comunidad de pescadores
de la ciudad vigila este santuario
amenazado por varios proyectos del
gobierno
una línea de gran velocidad un puente
marítimo o un nuevo aeropuerto
internacional provocará la destrucción
de una parte de los manglares
que juegan un papel esencial en la
protección de la ciudad
en caso de subida de las aguas o de
inundaciones
estos manglares captan y retienen el
excedente acumulado le hacen barrera e
impiden que el agua ingrese a la ciudad
es un mecanismo de control totalmente
natural es triste ver que la prioridad
de las autoridades es desarrollar nuevas
infraestructuras en vez de proteger lo
más preciado que tenemos para las
generaciones futuras y
un futuro que se anuncia invivible según
un reciente informe del gobierno las
temperaturas promedio en índia deberían
aumentar 4 como grados de aquí a 2100